hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines as you can see we're playing
real time right now because I figured
this is going to be that one episode in
which am I telling going to show my ship
and my [ __ ] my city I was going to say
say to you that I thought I didn't I
don't know why it might not but yeah
this is my sitting at the moment it's
currently the 17th of March and I don't
know if by the time that I've uploaded
this video I have got rid of the delay
with uploading videos maybe by a tiny
margin but this is still probably
uploaded a couple of days later but yeah
this is my city at the moment and in
order to glory and beauty and you know I
figured because I did all of these
timelapses and I never really got to
show what the city looks like right now
I decided to just show the fruit of my
labor so let's just take let's begin up
north we've got Rica over here which is
one big commercial zone because I have a
lot of demand for that I was just like
yeah I might as well try that that's
actually unpause of the game and we've
got the Russian city we've got the
rossion city over here and I'm not even
going to try to pronounce that it's just
a cool city I figured we've got Rome
over here which is called Rome for no
other reason that I had not no other
city name to come up with and we have
couche Stein over here which is caught
that because it's in the mountains and
this is a mountain if you view and live
in holland and you use the flat
countries this is pretty much in
mountain over here in holland and we've
got vancouver over here because it's got
loads of trees and I was like yeah I'm
pretty sure that Vancouver Vancouver has
loads of trees I am sorry about a
mispronouncing that it's very sorry and
salt lake city same thing loads of trees
I figured so I'm going to do that I'm
not really sure if I'm actually going to
keep this forest area because first of
all it doesn't really make too much
sense I mean the only connection that it
has for each little road is one one way
road that ends in a highway and begins
in a highway though not necessarily in
that order and I don't know if that if
that is the greatest thing same goes for
this little residential area over here
because it doesn't really seem to make
too much sense it's kind of stuck
between the highway and the
harbour over here the harbour of course
which has no cars but to bus lines and
is pretty much a traffic well problem
with buses alone no idea how I got to do
that but you know it works to get the
tourists in the rest of the city and
actually expect money so that I get
money which is the perfect situation
then we have Hong Kong and Singapore
over here wait up north though we still
have Seattle with which is nothing
except it does have some cool road
patterns pretty happy about that and
some flat blocks many flat blocks
actually for a neighborhood in this city
quite many and I do like that though I
do like to place these things next to my
highway because for one it just kind of
shows off the call tall buildings next
to the highway but then I was I was also
like yeah it could block the sound of
the cars for the houses that are over
here now i'm pretty sure that the
mechanicals this game don't work like
that but you know fantasy that's just
one I what I figured then we have Hong
Kong which is also one big commercial
area and therefore also called Hong Kong
and Singapore which is just a
residential area but it does have some
commercial stuff over here and some
officers I think over there too and this
is still one of my favorite places in
the city it just kind of has that GTA
look to me this is this is the kind of
highway on and off ramp that I imagine
every highway on an off ramp in America
to look like and I'm pretty sure it
doesn't then we have the ugly station of
which I have after 60 years of
investigation on this building I still
have not ink well found the door to this
thing that was literally no way you
where you can actually enter that seems
to be an issue over there but whatever
then we have this part of seattle which
which is still part of seattle because
it's just such a small neighborhood i
couldn't make it its own kind of
district over here so this is Seattle a
beautiful city actually do really like
this area really big park and I really
started noticing that if you zoom out if
you kind of have like the bird's eye
perspective which you normally have it
doesn't seem like a huge park but then
as soon as you start going first person
which
I was going to try to do over there but
I did not oh oh I think I did I don't
have the first person in modern stolen
anymore wow that's a bummer but you know
we can get pretty close with the normal
in Game kind of thing there we go that's
the thing I need that but yeah this
point is actually pretty big and it's
also got a pretty cool view of the
skyline though not necessarily over here
but more or less like from this this
little place over here it's pretty cool
and let me get rid of that and this is
probably a much better way to actually
navigate through the city although it
means that I can't see the district's
well I'll look at that in a bit and no
no I can't see the district names that
confuses me we have Frankfurt over here
which might seem a little strange
because it's in the middle of the park
but that just happened because of the
shape of the district as you can see
frag report used to be the commercial
area but then I was like me I'm gonna
call that Tokyo that's going to be its
own neighborhood so we have the downtown
area with all the skyscrapers over here
and of course they transmit our in the
middle because you do kind of want that
signature tower and by the way this
looks completely awesome from the which
wich one we call it is this yeah this is
a highway looks pretty cool from this
highway over here really got that
awesome skyline this game sure does live
up to its name I can say that so zooming
out we have got Osaka over here which is
the weeaboo region then we have talon
which is the bell tikka file region I
don't even think that's a word and we
have Amsterdam which is a pretty cool
region over here I'm calling these
things regions their districts even the
name district doesn't really appeal to
me it just kind of has that Hunger Games
ring to it to me and feel like just
calling it a neighborhood this seems
better I don't know but I do like
Amsterdam but especially because of that
building you know and the symmetrical
stuff with the apartment buildings and
the sides yeah it's a pretty cool
neighborhood and of course some of those
rings those residential rings because it
is on Amsterdam of course and then we
have Bucharest
because it has a cool kind of orthodox
looking church sounds like a like even
though this juice is supposed to be in
Ukraine you know Romania Ukraine it is
essentially the same thing I'm sorry
they're definitely not the same thing
we've got Indianapolis which was my
first neighborhood and Indianapolis is
still looking strong not going to get
too much bigger than that because i
think it is already one of the biggest
neighborhoods if not the biggest after
vancouver so not going to grow that too
much now we've got Mannheim which used
to be the industrial area but as you can
see it is far from industrial right now
because as soon as i discovered that
office buildings are actually industrial
buildings in this game as like oh yeah
remove all of that so i removed all the
industry over here and replace it with
all these kind of office buildings with
some residential stuff in the middle so
this is this is pretty much a communist
kind of neighborhood not really sure if
I'm too big of a fan of this but you
know it does look decent I suppose and
sometimes you also need some of these
lower class neighborhoods too and even
though I figured this would be in lower
halls in lower class neighborhood it's
still turned into a high class
neighborhood like seriously ninety-nine
percent of my population is highly
educated but whatever it doesn't really
seem like the most realistic thing but
that happens in this game when you give
you people all of those services so
moving on we have Dallas over here which
is a tiny little neighborhood which got
cut off by the by building this highway
and as soon as I built this highway I
saw all of the all of these smileys over
here like go me they totally did not
like that yeah then we have the overly
complicated highways over here and
Houston which is still one of my
favorite areas kind of like a suburb of
a suburb think i've called it that
before and Toronto which is nothing at
the moment and I'm probably going to
remove that because I think I have
plenty of forest industry with
Vladivostok and salt lake city so
definitely shouldn't have too much for
that and then we have Essen which also
used to be an industrial area but now
it's full of officers
and I I don't know this if this is too
much of clustering because this is just
offices in one big area and as you can
see these these roads are built for well
many many trucks to drive on them but
now it's being used by just a couple of
cars so that is I don't know that's a
great thing so I'm probably going to
redesign that neighborhood pretty soon
now we have holland which ironically is
the big [ __ ] hole of the city because
the hassle the industry and it has the
the burning burning stuff facilities so
but as you can see lots of traffic over
here but this thing as stupid as it
looks it's actually very practical and
everyone is using all of those on ramps
and as you can see that there aren't
really too many traffic problems over
here kind of have this traffic light
which is something that I did want to
avoid and I would like to say that avoid
traffic lights in any way you can but
sometimes you just need to have them but
other than that there is no congestion
over here at all so pretty happy about
that same goes for this though this what
isn't wrong over here they're actually
loading over there whatever that I'll
fix that at some point and then we have
Dubai which totally does not look like
the real life Dubai that is a terrible
place I mean I mean this one of course
and i think that's it yeah that's pretty
much it now i have the energy over here
with five of my son thing is I'm not
even I don't even know what these things
are called and we have some other
beautiful things in this city this thing
has some beautiful things to offer I
mean we have this complete spaghetti
interchanges what I call it I am the
inventor of the spaghetti interchange
the way you build it it's just like mmm
i have three highways and i need to
connect them let's just connect them
with random ramps everywhere and that
worked out fine because it does actually
as stupid as it looks it does actually
process the traffic pretty well because
you know you have one on ramp or offer
i'm for each highway so you can go in
all the directions and there was an
abandoned building just there but
there it is as that but that's getting
demolished very beautiful so this is the
city at the moment I do kinda like the
organic shape though it has a very
European kind of shape when we look at
the road pattern problem is I can't look
at the entire city without actually
going I can't look at the entire city I
can't look at the entire city anymore
without actually tilting the camera like
that but yeah I'm pretty happy about it
so far definitely a couple of things
that I still need to do in the future I
want to hook up this highway to this
highway of course so people can actually
use this then because as you can see
there's not too much traffic issues over
here yet but if I if I want to have some
neighborhoods over here I better have a
highway connection over there too and
that also means that this kind of ring
road around the center of the city is
also finished and what else am I going
to do a bit of expansion over here on
Vancouver and some more houses on the
hills over here because I do like those
houses even though they're very low
class right now I'm still going to plant
some trees over there and actually raise
the mint value and going to build some
buildings over here and in general just
expand definitely might want to change
the road pattern over here because it's
kind of busy with traffic as you can see
there's not really too much and you
taste silver right what is wrong with
you that is that is not congested at all
but if I look at this thing it's gonna
yeah it's going to show red in a couple
of places and I want my entire city to
be green even though I am that it that
is definitely not the case because some
areas are still quite well yeah red as
you can see so that is something to try
to fix in the future but I will do that
in the future and hopefully with the
train that I'm going to install over
here and also a passenger train and I'm
going to build a metro because my city
is getting pretty big right now even
though the population doesn't really
look like it I kind of want to fix those
issues but yeah that's the city for now
so thanks for watching and in the next
episode I will continue the time lapse
and actually work in the city again so
I'll see you then